every form of life on our planet from
species that swim in the water to those
that soar through the air from the
largest land mammals to the smallest of
insects all of these creatures and their
patterns of life are in some way or
another determined by the same invisible
force
gravity earth's gravitational pull
influences the parameters of animals
body plans maximum size and behavior
often limiting the ways in which life
can evolve but an earth-like level of
gravity isn't a constant throughout the
universe imagine a planet where gravity
is much much weaker than it is on earth
what kinds of fantastical forms of alien
life might evolve this speculative
hypothetical is the inspiration behind
the fictional alien world of anu a
creation of the talented artist sam
vilas boas the organisms on anew have
evolved into very different forms than
what could feasibly exist on our own
planet felis boas is an awesome world
builder often creating entire diagrams
going into the hypothetical science
behind the forms of low gravity life
populating the planet including an
entire taxonomy chart showing how the
various aliens we'll be exploring in
this video are related to each other if
you want to check out more of their work
i as usual have links to them in this
video's description so for this entry
into the archive we'll be taking a
documentary style deep dive into this
incredibly detailed low gravity world
not surprisingly the most fantastical
forms of life are in the air but let's
start where life often begins under the
waves the small rocky planet of anu
doesn't have much water compared to
earth but like our own planet
multicellular life likely began within
these depths starting at the base of the
new evolutionary tree we have the very
simple necroviscera jellyfish-like
organisms with emaciated forms that swim
in the low pressure depths these
lightweight organisms are small and
relatively uncomplicated but they're
basil to many other more fantastical
life forms on this planet moving up the
evolutionary tree we have these
fish-like life forms present in most
bodies of water on anew in gen triadics
are a basic example of such an organism
thanks to the semi-universal nature of
hydrodynamics the artist imagines these
life forms aren't much different from
fish on our own planet although they
don't have to worry quite as much about
water pressure in the depths thanks to
the lower gravity feeding on organisms
like engendriadics are species like the
litzcrista early predators about the
size of a tiger shark they usually hunt
alone ensnaring prey in their four-part
jaws which the artist imagines most
species on planet anu have due to some
common ancestry this is another species
which lives in the low pressure depths
drifting along on silent fins coming out
of the water on land organisms become
more complicated and start to truly
adopt unfamiliar forms which take
advantage of the low gravity this
spindly group is the flaminassis
organisms that likely wouldn't be able
to stand up at all on our own planet but
move just fine in a news gravity the
artist imagines they travel in packs
like you can see here along one of anu's
many beaches in this image a young
flaminassis picks a senseless fight with
another member to show its strength and
according to the artist loses quite
badly in another image two flame and
assists walk along the muddy bank of a
river looking for a high spot to warm
themselves in the sun temperature
regulation is critical to flaminassa's
survival the artist imagines that
specialized organs all along their
bodies accumulate in burn fats creating
heat when needed the flaminassis uses
adaptation in a specialized manner they
can heat the air stored in the space in
their upper jaw at night flaminasses
which can see an infrared light use
these flashes of heat to communicate
with one another as this image
demonstrates a larger land welding
organism is the draco centaurus a
species with legs too spindly to support
a sizeable body on our planet but whose
limbs are effective in its own low
gravity environment these omnivorous
creatures have evolved two long pointed
limbs for spearing prey which
superficially resembles the insectoid
claws on various types of mantises
despite their fearsome appearance the
large draco centaurus are a social
species with some signs of early
intelligence with packs exhibiting
significant social complexity even
larger still and less cunning are the
gargantuan brachiocornabus these mighty
grazers take full advantage of the low
gravity growing over three times the
size of an earth elephant their strange
antler-like front limbs are a powerful
form of defense making them essentially
untouchable but the brachycornobis
aren't the only large organisms on
planet anew the necrocampus are a single
massive life-form a cross-section
reveals that these grasses are just the
top part of the huge cell-like
structures that make up these curious
organisms the artist imagines some of
these cell networks form whole biomes of
their own and are so large they can be
seen from space in the places where two
of these expansive life forms meet
elevated areas form which makes the
organisms almost analogous to living
tectonic plates a genuinely unique
speculative concept but the land isn't
the true place to take advantage of a
news low gravity in the vast skies above
this small planet a truly unique
ecosystem has formed the skies of anew
are like an aerial ocean with
lightweight organisms gliding along on
fins similar to how creatures move
through the seas on earth near the
bottom of this ariel oceanic food chain
are the endocrine lightweight organisms
whose size allow them to be easily
scattered by the winds most live within
the equatorial forests on anew and can
display mesmerizing colors like tropical
birds on our own planet other endocrine
have adapted to the snowy lands north of
the equator like this fuzzy sleek
species whose color helps it blend in
with the snowfall often called wolves
due to their pack hunting behavior these
species can both leap great distances to
catch prey and scavenge on the ground
although they aren't true flyers like
their relatives higher up in the
atmosphere larger organisms take flight
this is an example of a folio palum a
brightly colored herbivore that sails
along three sets of paddle-like wings
these colorful noodles eat leaves and
giant spores which are sometimes
released into the air by specific plants
the idea of flying spores reminds me of
dandelion seeds which as i'm sure you
know can also become airborne on gusts
of wind but where there's herbivores
there are carnivores the endoptera are
group of large equatorial predators
which the artist has nicknamed the air
sharks one specific species is the
orbalus a high-altitude ambush predator
that specializes in capturing low-flying
prey their keen eyes allow them to scan
for prey far below them then dive down
at high speeds and pierce their target
with their front limbs like birds on
earth endoptera will sometimes rest on
the trunks of tall vegetation in between
periods of searching for food which can
be a draining ordeal here a group takes
a break after an unsuccessful hunt
looking for some shade where they might
hopefully get some rest another type of
endoptera are the stella plumo
snake-like predators that fly along the
riverbanks of a region called eden
valley a biome surrounding the largest
lakes on planet anew and one with the
highest concentration of biomass of any
region in this lush environment the
serpentine stella plumo flourish in
large numbers catching small creatures
when they spot them from above
a larger endoptera are the bielavus
qualis lion-sized aerial predators that
glide and packs through the skies above
mountainous regions they hunt and eat
any terrestrial animals on the mountain
ranges that they can take down which
likely includes most species of the
aforementioned flaminassus but there are
some organisms in the skies far too
large for most predators to even
consider hunting the abzu long which
actually fall into the endoptera
classification despite being herbivores
have long narrow bodies which wouldn't
be able to take to the air at all in
earth's gravity on anew however the abzu
long rule these clear skies or at least
mostly in truth even the massive abzu
long aren't completely safe not when the
chromos rex is on the prowl the biggest
flying creature in the skies of anew
these giant organisms almost resemble
small airplanes and consume anything
they can fit in their mouths which as
this diagram shows is quite a lot as the
artist imagines the chromos rex has not
a four but a six part jaw that can fit
around almost anything a true apex of
the low-gravity ocean-like skies
the unique low-gravity life-forms of
planet anu are just one speculative
possibility of what life on another
planet with lower gravity than our own
might look like if you liked exploring
this fictional world however consider
supporting sam vilas boas by clicking
the links below there are other species
of anew on their page which i didn't
have time to get to here so check those
out if you're interested and as always
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
entry please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
also i'm now on twitter where i
occasionally post polls teasers and
other fun stuff so follow me there if
you're interested i've got a link to it
in my description and on my home page
see you in the next video
you